hi and welcome to my video series of
piyo techniques explained in five
minutes where I explain a concept of
biology in less than five minutes or so
if you haven't yet subscribed to my
channel hit that subscribe button
why are you waiting for now please leave
some comments at the end of this video
this would keep me motivated to make
more videos like this
in this installment we'll be learning
about cDNA libraries so a cDNA library
is a combination of all cloned cDNA
fragments which is comprising of the
transcriptome of the cell at a given
point of time under a given condition so
if we consider a cell it would have a
lot of DNA and at the point of time all
of these DNA won't be expressing right
few of these DNA would Express I mean
the transcription would happen from few
of these DNA and that would give rise to
the transcriptome of the cell at that
point of time so in short cDNA library
represents a pool of mRNA at a given
point of time under a certain condition
a same cell would have different
transcription profile under two
different conditions and a different
time point right so a set different type
of cells beat a neuron beta epithelial
cell be the muscular cell it would have
different kind of transcriptomes
because different kind of genes are
expressed in these tissues which would
give rise to the changes right so we if
we compare cDNA library to a genomic DNA
library then a genomic DNA would contain
all the sequence which comprises both
eggs on and introns of a gene whereas
the cDNA libraries could not have any
introns because the cDNA library is
constructed from the mRNA and it
converted to cDNA so it would only have
sequence information about exons the
expressing part right
now genomic DNA library would contain
representation of the all genes of that
particular cell let's say that sin has
26,000 genes so all of these information
about that all these 26,000 genes would
be encompassed in these genomic DNA
library but all these 26,000 genes do
not express under same condition and
same time point so cDNA library would be
a small subset of the genomic DNA
library it would have information about
few genes that are expressed at that
particular type point or at that
particular condition so these are the
defining differences between the genomic
DNA and cDNA library now let's look at
how we can prepare a cDNA library so
first step is imagine you have your sale
of interest so let's say you want to
extract a cDNA library of this common
epithelial cell now you take a cell
popular cell population and you have to
realize the cell to extract it are its
RNA right after that the RNA that we
have extracted we would be converting it
into complimentary DNA with particular
reaction conditions which I won't be
discussing in this particular video but
I have a simple video on that now this
cDNA would be cloned inside specific
expression vectors and now we can use
these expression vectors which can
contain specific fragments of the cDNA
of that particular cell and we can
transform that using normal heat shock
method we can combine it with the
component cell and then we can perform
the heat shock where by changing in
subtlety change in temperature would
allow the incorporation of those cDNA
containing plasmid
into the component cell after that we
can play those comparin cells on a
particular plate with particular
antibiotic resistance which would allow
us the selection so after a point of
time we would start seeing colonies in
the plate where we have transformed our
bacteria right and expected that these
bacteria this bacterial plate which
which would have all the representation
of the transcriptome in format of cDNA
now the question comes okay we know it
would possibly has all the CDNs from the
cells that we want from the cell that we
wanted it to be extracted but how would
I know it is present so we need a
screening method so how do we screen the
cDNA library so next couple of minutes
let's talk about how we can screen the
cDNA library so first step first is the
replica plating so we have to put a
nitrocellulose membrane or a nylon
membrane and the imprint of the colonies
would come on to that membrane now we
know which gene we are looking for so we
can use a radio level low probe or any
kind of level probe and put that on the
membrane and allow it for hybridization
so when the hybridization is done and we
plot I mean develop this particular
hyper nylon membrane under
autoradiograph so we can see a
particular colony is present so that
most likely to have our gene of interest
so now we can go back to our replica
plate and select that particular colony
grow that particular colony in bulk and
do whatever we like to do with our gene
of interest right so in this way we can
screen our cDNA colony but there is
certain problem with making cDNA
libraries in bacteria the alternative is
to make the cDNA library in lamda
fudgicle based cloning vectors if you
don't know about lambda phage based
cloning vectors I have a separate video
on lambda for its best conic cloning
vectors
so you can check that out first now
there are dedicated lambda fudge
insertion vectors which are used to
produce cDNA libraries there are lambda
G t10 and lambda GT 11 series the
biggest advantage of these lambda
vectors is they have bigger carrying
capacity because all the genes are not
small right so some genes are pretty big
so it gives us more flexibility in terms
of the carrying capacity and you can
also have a lags reporter based easy
screening system in this lambda GT 11
series advanced lambda phage based
vectors so which would give us advantage
and these days we have lambdas app
series which are even bigger carrying
capacity in terms of carrying capacity
they are like huge so they can carry as
big as like 10 KB fragments and
relatively it is easy to screen these
lambdas app vectors in terms of cDNA
library so these days people prefer
lambda phage vents based cloning system
over bacterial clearing system I hope
you enjoyed this video if you liked this
video give it a quick thumbs up don't
forget to Like share and subscribe thank
you